ja willkommen zur aktuellen Sendung
heute haben wir uns wieder ein
spannendes Thema vorgeknöpft im Kontext
der politischen Philosophie heute geht
es um das Thema politische Herrschaft
politische Herrschaft ist einer der
zentralbegriffe genau genommen der
Begriff der Herrschaft Herrschaft heißt
konkret dass es hier um Macht Ausübung
geht und das führt wieder zum Thema
macht und dann mache ich oben rechts
einen Link rein zu dieser Sendung wir
haben uns ein paar Fragen genommen eine
Frage lautet welche Herrschaftsformen
gibt es natürlich gibt es sehr viele
politische Herrschaftsformen wir werden
in der heutigen Sendung die wichtigsten
zumindest nach Aristoteles diskutieren
wir werden auch anhand dieser
Herrschaftsform fragen welche
Herrschaftsform ist die beste was ist
die beste Herrschaftsform und genauso
wollen wir fragen welche Herrschaftsform
ist die schlechteste natürlich muss man
hier immer die Kriterien auch dafür
angeben Kriterien sollte natürlich sein
für die ganze Welt idealerweise für alle
vernünftigen Wesen die irgendwie
Zusammenleben ansonsten für die
jeweilige politische Gesellschaft die
Polis und dann eine Frage die wir auch
nicht ignorieren dürfen weil sie für das
herrschaftsverständnis und für die
Herrschaftsform sehr wichtig ist nämlich
die Frage nach der
herrschaftslegitimation also die
Begründung die
Rechtfertigung diese Frage wollen wir
auch aufwerfen ich hatte schon gesagt
der Begriff der politischen Herrschaft
ist einer der wichtigsten Begriffe im
Kontext der politischen Philosophie was
ist Herrschaft Herrschaft ist eine Form
der intersubjektiven Machtausübung
natürlich kann man auch sagen es gibt
sowas wie Selbstherrschaft das ist dann
aber nicht mehr streng Genom politisch
ich kann natürlich auch über meine
Neigungen und Triebe Herrin oder Herr
sein das ist z.B das Modell bei Immanuel
Kant oder auch das Modell der Stoiker
wenn es darum geht an inneren
Seelenfrieden zu gewinnen aber hier geht
es jetzt um intersubjektive
machttausübung und diese machttausübung
kann gelingen sie kann aber auch
scheitern gelingen kann man wieder in
zwei verschiedenen Hinsichten verstehen
macht kann wirksam sein also macht kann
zu Herrscher führen dann schließt sich
wieder die Frage an ob diese Herrschaft
auch gerecht ist ob sie wirklich auch
legitim ist und ob sie gut ist für die
Gesellschaft Herrschaft ist immer
abhängig von herrschaftsbegründung und
herrschaftslegitimation
also jede Person die eine Herrschaft
anstrebt die versucht immer Gründe für
diese Herrschaft zu
entwickeln ihre Herrschaft zu motivieren
und sozusagen zu unterbauen zu
unterfüttern
Aristoteles ist einer der wichtigsten
auch einer der ersten politischen Denker
wir finden schon bei Platon sowas wie
ein politisches Denken in seiner Schrift
politea der Staat dort sehen wir aber
dass der Staat im Wesen ichen vor dem
Hintergrund philosophischer Interessen
idealphilosophischer Annahmen entwickelt
wird es geht um den ST der
philosophenkönige und häufig wird Platon
vorgeworfen das sein nur so ein
Idealismus gewesen der nichts mit der
Realität zu tun habe und häufig wird
auch gesagt dagegen war Aristoteles eher
ein Realist so kann man es sehen man
kann aber auch vielleicht so
argumentieren dass Aristoteles noch
stärker begrifflich unter Scheidungen
einführt die das Verhältnis von macht
ausübenden Subjekten in Gesellschaften
betreffen und in diesem Sinne werden
auch verschiedene Auffassungen darüber
vertreten wie Herrschaft durch
Machtausübung geregelt werden sollte
welche Herrschaftsform die beste sein
und Aristoteles unterscheidet eben
verschiedene Herrschaftsform im Sinne
seines analytischen begrifflichen
Zugriffs und er Kat isiert die jetzt
weiter und zwar hinsichtlich der Anzahl
der herrschenden also die Frage wer
herrscht wie viele herrschen und die
Frage wie herrschen sie herrschen sie
gut oder schlecht und das Kriterium für
diese Frage ist das
Gemeinwohl jetzt hat er hier eine
interessante Unterscheidung nämlich er
sagt die gute Herrschaft des Einzelnen
hinichlich der Anzahl ist die
Monarchie die schlechte es gibt immer so
eine schlechte Form immer binär die
schlechte ist die
also ein Tyrann der herrscht alleine
aber nicht im Sinne des Gemeinwohls wie
wir hier sagen es gibt auch noch ein
Zwischenglied nämlich die Herrschaft der
wenigen das ist dann im guten Falle die
Aristokratie Aristokratie heißt wörtlich
übersetzt die Herrschaft der besten
aristos ist das der beste und es gibt
aber auch noch die Herrschaft der
Oligarchie Oligarchen das kennt man aus
manchen staten das heißt oligos ist
einfach wenig gering das sind die
wenigen die herrschen und nach
Aristoteles sind die nicht auf das
Allgemeinwohl bedacht jetzt kann man
sich noch Gedanken machen über die
Herrschaft der vielen also nicht nur der
einigen und des einen s der vielen und
da sagte ist die gute V die politie das
ist die Herrschaft der Tüchtigen und
also die der vielen gut tauglich
arbeitenden auch reichen undter
Umständen und die schlechte Form
erstaunlicherweise das was den Namen
Demokratie hier läuft und wir würden ja
sagen das ist eigentlich die Bestform
allerdings versteht aristotel die
Demokratie als die Herrschaft der Armen
man könnte vielleicht auch sagen die
Herrschaft des Pöbels einfach so eine
vielherrschaft ohne dass wirkliche
Leistung dahinter ist und Motivation
natürlich ist so gesehen dann die
Demokratie problematisch das muss man
natürlich zugeben es hängt davon ab wie
man den Begriff jetzt
steht das ist eben diese Begründung es
mag heutzutage erstaunlich erscheinen
aber es geht ih immer um die Interessen
der Tüchtigen der fähigen und die wird
hier verletzt diese
Interesse hier gibt's eine Übersicht aus
Wikipedia sehr hilfreich aber das haben
wir eigentlich schon besprochen immer
die Kriterien nach der Frage geordnet
wer herrscht einer wenige oder viele und
die Frage dann ist die gut legitim oder
ist sie nicht gut weil sie nur dem
Eigennutz
dient die Demokratie ist als eine
vielherrschaft wo die vielen nur
deswegen herrschen oder politisch tätig
sind damit es Ihnen selbst nützt sie
haben praktisch kein Interesse über sich
hinaus und so gesehen wäre das natürlich
nicht die ideale Demokratie das macht
auf jeden Fall Sinn Herrschaft ist jetzt
allgemeine gesagt systematische gesagt
jetzt sich mehr nur historisch auf
Aristoteles bezogen kein politisch
stabiler Zustand der irgendwie einfach
so garantiert ist sondern Herrschaft
muss immer erworben werden das geht
immer um die Frage nach dem
herrschaftserwerb und diese Frage wird
häufig außercht gelassen häufig wird
immer so getan als würde irgendjemand
herrschen und dann herrscht die nächste
Person oder die nächste Menge das
Spannende ist viel mehr der Übergang die
Wechsel zwischen verschiedenen
Herrschaftsformen oder auch Personen und
Gruppierung die herrschen da wird
Herrschaft istst politisch
interessant politische Herrschaft kann
nämlich teilweise an sich gerissen
werden ich darf an den das Wort der
Machtergreifung im des
Nationalsozialismus erinnern wobei auch
hier die Debatte immer die ist war das
jetzt wirklich Machtergreifung oder
nicht viel mehr
machtüberlassung dass die weimach
Republik eh nicht mehr die Demokratie
die
wollte also das kann man kann man sich
immer streiten ob jetzt es hier eine
machgreifung ist das setzt voraus dass
ich jemand die Macht mit Gewalt an sich
reißt und eine andere Instanz die Gewalt
gerne noch hätte es gibt natürlich auch
noch die heutzutage Demokratien
idealerweise übliche Form der
Machtübertragung der geregelten
Machtübertragung z.B durch
Wahlverfahren das sind ganz geregelte
legitimations Verfahren die sich bewährt
haben im ersten Fall im Falle des der
Machtergreifung wenn man die Macht an
sich reiß dann hat es häufig hier ein
Sturz zufolge oder eine Revolution
Französische
Revolution es kann eine geregelte Form
annehmen die Macht Ergreifung oder die
Macht Übernahme und es kann auch eine
geregelte Form
geben hier kann man noch unterscheiden
dass es häufig in monarchischen System
SAS wie Gottesgnadentum gab dass man
sich auf theologische Bezüge stützte und
sich dadurch die Herrschaft legitimierte
es kann auch sein dass man sich auf die
Abstammung rufen wollte und sagte ich
gehörre dem Adel an häufig beruft sich
natürlich auch dann der Adel auf
theologische
äh
legitimationsstrategien das hängt häufig
auch eng miteinander zusammen also wir
sehen es gibt eine ganze Vielfalt von
herrschafts Beanspruchung
herrschafts Beanspruchung und
herrschaftsstrategien
der Legitimation und es kommt darauf an
diese
legitimationsversuche immer kritisch zu
betrachten die Frage nach der
herrschaftslegitimation ist politisch
zentral warum sie ist kein bloß
theoretisches Unternehmen was neben der
aktuellen tatsächlichen wirkmächtigen
Herrschaft betrieben wird so als eine
begleitreflexion sondern die
herrschaftslegitimation ist selbst eine
Form der Herrschaftsausübung und zwar
die erste erst auf dieser Basis kann
dann auch tatsächlich die Herrschaft
ausgeübt werden wenn sie denn erworben
wurde auf welche Weise auch immer also
jede Herrschaft will ein Unterbau haben
ein begründungsunterbau auf dem sie dann
Biert es geht hier mit anderen Worten um
sowas wie politische Normativität
Normativität sind also
geltungssätze
bindende Annahmen bindende Gesetze
ähm um die Frage aus welchen
Gründen
wir die Herrschaft besitzen und damit
Macht ausüben dürfen die Begründung die
normative Begründung sie zeigt sich vor
allem in Form von politischen Ideologien
sind rechtfertigungssysteme von
Weltanschauung
und H haben haben wir verschiedene
Beispiele z.B Nationalsozialismus
Faschismus aber auch Kommunismus sind
globale Systeme die gehen häufig auch in
Richtung der
Ideologie es gibt aber auch
demokratische Systeme
die eine Form von Grundposition
darstellen wie z.B Liberalismus oder
Sozialismus das sehen wir in der
deutschen Regierung auch sonst in Europa
sich abwechseln auch in den USA die
Republik die Demokraten die Republikaner
sind eher liberal die Demokraten eher
sozialistisch W man das sagen kann auch
das sind Herrschaftsformen die man jetzt
vielleicht nicht Ideologie nennen muss
im starken Sinne aber sind auch Formen
der Argumentation für eine bestimmte
Herrschaftsform natürlich immer noch im
Rahmen der Demokratie in den genannten
Fällen ja das war ein kurz Überblick
über die verschiedenen Dimensionen von
Herrschaft ein wirklich zentraler
politischer Begriff ich bedanke mich für
die auf ksamkeit bis zu einer nächsten
Folge